my colleague from the nfl media group
one of our favorites back here on the
show ian rappaport how are you ian
what's going on rich how are you well
lots is going on brother let's jump into
it i know you're busy man we all uh we
all have so much to to hit here it was
one of the craziest weeks
ever um it started with the rams
shocking us with
uh von miller and then ended supposedly
with the rams shocking us with odell
beckham and then that crazy game broke
out last night let's start with odell
uh how did he wind up on the rams
ian well you know he had at least five
offers uh i think more but at least five
that we know of um no actually it would
be six it would include the rams so at
least six offers
and you know i think they were all
pretty similar a couple were around the
minimum packers were minimum
chiefs were minimum new orleans was a
little more
seattle's was a little more the patriots
was a little more and the rams was kind
of in the ballpark but they were like
kind of a stealth team
and you know because they didn't really
like there was a report that he was
narrowing down to three teams the rams
weren't one of them and
um
you know i think what what happened from
his side the model side is he basically
told the rams like
let's keep talking like i know the
money's not crazy but let's keep talking
um
because at the beginning of this he
identified the packers and rams as his
top two teams
he knew there'd be some interest from
the packers i don't think he knew
there'd be any interest from the rams so
he kind of prodded them on a little bit
and then they started talking and then
von miller got involved and then jaylen
ramsey got involved and uh it was a
whole big recruiting thing and in the
end it was down to the packers and rams
and um i think he you know i think he
ends up making a good choice that makes
a lot of sense yeah i think so uh two um
you know and i gotta have trent dill for
later on to talk about how the x's and
o's might or might not work out so it's
amazing you know he and vaughn are tight
so
von g uh the acquisition on monday he
doesn't play on sunday but already pays
dividends to get odell there on the
following thursday essentially that's
what you're saying
you know we'll see on um what happens
with vaughn i'm not even sure he's
playing this week you know because i
think the rams have a buy rents have a
buy next week right yes they do
yeah so
i think there's definitely we'll see
what happens but there was definitely
some talk of
waiting till after the buy to make sure
vog's ankle is fully and 100 healed so
we'll see what ends up happening um but
yeah i mean you know he's a
he's a big time star power guy odell's a
big time star power guy
they're in a city where
you know that really works um
i'm i'm curious about the actual
football part of it because
you know the rams ribs have some pretty
good receivers um and i think they would
be fine with
cup and jefferson and robert woods and
did they need odell probably not um
but it's not a bad you know third or
fourth receiver to throw out there right
but the chiefs were in on him huh and
and and i guess that that's you know the
rams certainly
um
say
getting them and preventing them from
going to green bay or new orleans those
are the teams that you'd mentioned
seattle as well in their division so
you're preventing them from going
somewhere in your division and then
other places in your conference and then
eventually potentially to a team that i
know is
is not looking super right now but the
last two afc super bowl combatants in
the chiefs that's that's a plus two you
know so um yeah assuming that he's going
to be
you know assuming that he's going to be
a net positive right like the money it's
sort of like who cares right i mean
you know the reason you save money
against the cap is fiddling with the
carolina panthers like the reason to
save money this time of year is to be
able to spend it like this it's not like
you're going to spend it on much else
right right so
um the money's sort of whatever you just
have to hope odell is in that positive i
know in cleveland he was not
and that's not like a shot at all it's
literally just the fact like they are a
better team when he's not on the field
you hope it is the opposite with the
rams ian rap report here on the rich
eisen show how did cam wind up with
carolina
ian
give me the storyline there so a lot of
hard conversations um
and one specific so you know they knew
probably tuesday that sam darnold's
injury was pretty bad
now it's funny because like well it's
not funny but it's interesting because
darnold looked really bad and i think we
all the public decided that he just
sucked
but reality was he was pretty badly
injured and i'm not sure how many people
actually knew that not a lot of people
um
and he you know just couldn't make
couldn't make like regular throws and
realize that it's hard to make regular
throws with a cracked shoulder
which is interesting i learned that this
week
and so they found out how bad darnold's
injury was
and it was like do we stick with pj
walker who we like or should we just
should we just do it like let's just see
if kevin's interested so matt rule
called cam up on tuesday night and was
like
are you interested and he said yeah i'm
interested
so they got in the room
david tepper stephen drummond the vp of
football operations scott fitter cam
dude and his dad
and
talked it through talked about the way
everyone left talked about
the sort of divorce
realized that they were better together
than a part
and i got together and it was
i mean it really is a little bit surreal
and he's on the practice field as we
speak and i still can't believe it yeah
i know i saw him arriving number one and
carolina he must be it must be weird for
him too he thought he'd never do this
again and then football can be a a crazy
thing um did the saints never
think about cam reach out to him at all
because
you'd have to wonder if odell would have
gone home to them
if if it wasn't you know a second slash
third string quarterback that's going to
be starting
for them the rest of the year
i mean
i i don't i i didn't know that the
saints i don't know that the saints
reached out to can but i do know that uh
there were quarterback questions
from o'dell on the same like i think he
he really liked to think he really liked
sean payton just like he really liked
bill belichick he talked to bill
belichick personally a couple times um
it was just the quarterback it's just
trevor simeon you know and i
not that my football exes knows means
very much you know that's not what i do
um i think trevor simeon will be good
enough to
lead the saints where they want to go he
does exactly what sean payton wants to
do and that is
valuable he just follows his directions
which is definitely something
but if you're a
you know potentially superstar receiver
that's not what you want um so i think
that was why the state kind
didn't end up with odell so cam spoke to
bill huh personally a couple of
conversations no odell odell right sorry
odell spoke to bill personally a couple
times
huh okay
this is amazing i mean uh unbelievable a
mid-season free agency tour for odell
beckham jr is just the latest twist and
turn you know you know it was it was
weird i have to say too because you know
like these free agency is crazy you know
march is absolutely bananas right
um and
just like personally i was not totally
ready for like
the toll that this would take like the
last two weeks feel like they've been
two months
you know like myself finally signed and
it was a craziness yesterday and i was
fun i was like all right man like let's
just have a normal week one you know i
know i as i said that the von um
surprise acquisition by the rams and
then the
odell surprise signing by the the rams
in the in between is the the wildest nfl
yada yada yada of all time you know it's
kind of crazy man what the yada yada
yada was and in terms of that ian
rappaport what can you tell me about
aaron rodgers um you know what do you
think he'll be cleared saturday and play
sunday and that's it it'll be as simple
as that yeah
yeah i mean he should be cleared and you
know the more we go through these
circumstances the more we learn about
them
he really doesn't have to do very much
of anything like he does not need a
negative testimony he's gone through 10
days right what dr alan sills told judy
bautista yesterday
is when players have coveted
sometimes they test positive anyway
right even if they are no longer able to
transmit even if they're no longer
contagious they still test positive so
he doesn't need a negative test he
basically just needs to be cleared by a
doctor
and
not have symptoms
so
i mean he should be cleared and should
be able to go on something and any word
as to his physical well-being i mean
this
this uh does he again i i i know he's a
uh uh
a reigning mvp in in in rock-solid shape
and i'm a 52-year-old father of three
but it took me a while to actually get
my sea legs on anything like without not
feeling exhausted at six o'clock at
night and people can obviously have
different feelings
he'll be able to play a national
football league game at a high level
against the seattle seahawks coming off
a bye and and off we go best you can
tell i believe so um but i will say this
like there's been a couple examples this
year chandler jones was one you know
chandler jones had a i would say a
fairly significant bout with cobin
was eligible this was early in the
season was eligible to come off the
cover list on a saturday
didn't come off the list and everybody
was like why he's able to like what's
the deal
but the reason he didn't was because
he wasn't ready like he just didn't feel
well like he he no longer had covert but
he just felt crappy right so he didn't
play he played the next week i think
roger should be good friends like his
symptoms are very minimal
but you're right like i would say the
same thing with the browns like you know
they have
uh
they have nick chubb on the cover list
this week like theoretically he could be
cleared by sunday i'm not sure he plays
just because he hasn't practiced all
week it's so difficult it really is what
about kyler murray and uh deandre
hopkins in the the arizona cardinals can
we see colt mccoy for a second straight
week what do you think here
uh kyler is on the practice field now
that's good so the fact that he's
practicing
is at least a sign that he's got a real
shot we'll see what happens like i
assume he'll be a game time decision
again
um
but practicing is better than not
practicing so
he's got a shot deandre hopkins no
no practice again
so
you know i would say he probably doesn't
have a great shot okay um now uh a
couple last things for you ian wrap
before i send you off into your friday
what was with two and not starting last
night and then he gets in and then
it's just weird man the whole
quarterback handling of this team
is so weird from kicking the tires onto
sean watson two weeks before playing
season
then getting the rare owner
player on another team uh permission to
speak
prior to a trade deadline doesn't happen
they put the genie back in the bottle i
guess but tua doesn't start and then
comes out and wins
is he the guy moving like what the hell
is going on there is just the general
sense
of the question um
so here is my sentence
brian forest had two options on thursday
he had a not fully healthy tua or he had
a fully healthy
jacobi percent now sometimes
not fully healthy quarterbacks are
better
than anyone literally anyone
they did not believe that was the case
so jacoby brissett starts
looks not very good honestly
um
and tweaks his knee and goes down
writhing in pain now the fact that he
was able to come back and get cleared
is okay but it did not mean he was 100
so then your options for flores are a
not 100 jacobi beset were not 100
percent two
and he chose a not 100 to it after
watching the offense
struggle mightily with percent who
you know
was not very good just was not there yet
so his choice was to him and what
resulted was
some wobbly throws and some kind of not
great moments but also some good moments
you know like
there were some
some leadership moments from two of them
there were some big time big time plays
despite an injury despite a fractured
finger and all that like
in the end it really really worked out
uh for brian flores and for the miami
dolphins but the plan is still let's
let's get to sean watson in the fold in
in march right i mean how can you say
that's not after you try to do it in in
november
correct well depending on depending on
if things are are clear enough and he's
a viable citizen football player correct
right but that's that's a big that's a
big depending if right because
if steven ross you know my understanding
was sean watson was not traded
because his cases were not settled
well how much more clarity are we going
to have by february march are we really
going to have that much more clarity and
if stephen ross wouldn't do it then
would he do it in
march
also
could be a lot more teams interested i
would expect carolina panthers to be
interested as well i would think they're
not going to be the only team
probably going to be
some other very interested team so
i think the dolphins will probably
explore again
but i would have i would definitely have
some questions all right last one for
you ian uh
the taunting rule and flag that uh got
called on cassius marsh on monday night
football peri fuel this svp of
officiating folded into a 90-second
video that was tweeted out from the uh
twitter official account of the nfl
officiating says
yeah good call
why what are you hearing do they really
want that called do they real or they're
just backing up their official in their
way and telling everybody else don't do
that again
what can you tell me on this i mean why
i mean they've actually been really
consistent they've been
pro-taunting not protons and
pro-taunting rules for anti-talking
they have been every time they've had
the chance to say oh that went you know
over the line whatever
they have not they have said taunting is
not good and you should not do it and if
you do it you'll be penalized now for
that one specifically
on one hand like what did he really do
he just basically stood there and stared
at the sideline
on the other hand it was clear what his
intent was he
was basically posing
in front of the other team looking at
their sideline
now if i was on the other team would i
be offended no i'd probably be more
offended by his ridiculous karate kick
celebration
[Music]
but i understand it
i understand why that was haunting and i
understand why the nfl does not believe
that has a place and i understand why he
was flagged so
there there was no no debate best you
can tell like there was like yeah sure
let's have
let's have a game totally potentially
decided by something like that and we're
cool with it and and fans are outraged
and players or players think that
they're being put upon
i mean honestly
you know no i get it but it's the same
issue as
you know oh would you really want to
call that penalty
at this time like oh that's sort of
passing you know that's passenger
appearance but you know let them play in
the final two minutes it's like
isn't a penalty just a penalty
no i've heard that for all 18 years that
i've been with nfl network ian and um
i've always had a problem with it
believe it
um i i do believe that that that things
should be a foul called no matter what
but then there are others in a gray area
that if it's a gray area just keep the
keep the flag in your in your pocket and
then there was no conversation what did
they what are you hearing about corenti
he didn't bump the guy he didn't hip
check him like that didn't happen
well what are you hearing about that one
uh in the nfl uh offices
they do not believe that there was a hip
check okay
all right you know they do not believe
there was anything intentional okay all
right that's there that's a difference
there's a difference between that yeah
yeah yeah it's like is it differing out
the word oh no no no no that's if he
thinks he's not intentional then that's
you know honestly you can lose your
balance or something like that i don't
know
ian thanks for the commented people all
the time thank you sir take care of
yourself we'll chat on sunday game day
morning look forward to it as always
you're ready to go rap report
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here